in this video i'm going to make some  predictions in terms of the general size  and design of the mac pro the price the  release date the overall performance and  much more so let's jump right in i  believe that apple will take two or four  m1 max dies and toss them into a single  soc package the 40 core cpu could score  up to 49 348 points you'll have up to  256 gigs unified memory and  128 gpu cores for the base model i  expect it to come with a 20 core cpu a  bend 48 core gpu 64 gigs of unified  memory and a one terabyte ssd it'll  start anywhere from 4 thousand to six  thousand dollars and then top of the  line 40 core chip with 128 gpu cores and  256 gigs of ram will cost somewhere  around 8 000  for that crazy upgrade